vous montez pour le Salon de
l'Agriculture
[Musique]
oui je suis la 320 excusez-moi je me
demandais pourquoi il y a pas de mini
truc dans le mini bar
oui non deux étoiles quoi
je ne vous pouvez pas porter à longueur
de journée non vous me payez pour vendre
des fringues que je pourrais jamais
payer avec ce que vous me payez
ça
[Musique]
moi à 6h57
moi aussi 6h57 qu'est-ce que tu fous je
te cherche partout
[Musique]
c'est moi moi dans 20 ans elle te
ressemble trop pas parfois tu es hyper
terre à terre je te dis que cette fille
c'est moi
je m'imagine des choses vrai
Margot j'ai pas couché avec lui que tu
dis que tu dis non mais je vous signale
que je vous entends là bon toi tu t'es
fait tirer ton scooter et Margot sa
carte bleue elle passe plus vous avez
même pas fini de payer en plus
je fume on a commencé quand moi il y a
15 ans donc toi dans 5 vous connaissez
d'où en fait de Paris
[Musique]
ça va venir
tu vas rester un moment avec lui
est-ce qu'un Nicolas un chauffeur de
taxi un verre au Colisée ça te dit
quelque chose